whoa that piece was hanging outside what
just happened here that's the problem
that's definitely a problem for Delta by
he needs to get after the c7 punt I
don't know how he's plan to get there
but he needs to somehow attack it he's
not getting there in time because the
rook is taking on c6 so Hikaru with
brilliant pre moves King g7 was an
option there take take on h6 I take my
g6 first okay this is going down to the
wire work to be eight
I prefer to be it really quickly I'm
gonna kick to that and get my rope to ca
now play f3 g for something like that
try trade pieces I don't think you're
making this happen though and g3 g4
China get the pawn running g5 I didn't
like that move f3 oh my gosh mutual time
trouble here maybe two check that you
check his coming and what's nice um jibs
oh what's going on here ninety-two C -
hey cars Oh No good nice to see one take
on a three take about three oh my god
you have to take on a three dude they
should need to be a brilliant pre-move
not a primo he stopped the pre move that
is Hikaru Nakamura showing off his
bullet skills because he blundered we
all saw him blunder with night to see
one then after rook takes he when he was
I don't know it's a crazy
you should I get a spawn to see when I'm
not sure but here you have to just take
this pawn f3 you can no longer lose the
game and Bishop d3 cuts off the rook
from the pre move that he was trying to
make of rook takes f3 and that is how
you win bullet games that you may have
no business winning over the board
Nakara nakamura shows excellent just its
prowess there at that moment who we take
a breath we see a car Nakamura take the
grand prize
I mean Tabata bike you gotta tip your
cap off to him he was playing on shaky
connection he made it all the way to the
final he won a game on demand to take a
car not more into the bullet and then in
the bullet his back was against the wall
he was losing he almost survive in a
very clever Bishop d3 interception by
Hakkar Nakamura wins him this speed
chess champion